hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's help one
what the
did i see something over there no i
think it was just the button never mind
everybody falls alarm
cue the panic later uh welcome back to
five nights at freddy's help wanted we
have
two challenges ahead of us we've got oh
sorry we've got three challenges ahead
of us we gotta get through
five nights at freddy's two night five
five nights at freddy's three
night five and then the dark room so
that shouldn't be
too bad i imagine anyway if it is too
bad
then i'm going to be mad oh god i
keep thinking that you change but you
don't
change do you you wouldn't do that to me
would you
so back to five nights at freddy's 2 i
don't remember
exactly what to do but we're going to
find out and i'm going to kick the ass
of
every single animatronic in this place
ah frick
what the hell hi oh [ __ ]
oh wait hang on um okay so light
light light light light light mask
shut up shut up shut up okay light light
light why is everything weirdly lighted
this is fine because i can multitask as
long as i can multitask
i'll be good man okay all right if that
guy could just shut up
why why why why okay if that guy could
just shut up
oh hi that's horrifying okay
yeah this is easy all i gotta do is keep
this wound
keep looking at you and when you decide
to enter in here
uh die it's as simple as that okay can i
please dear for the love of jehovah's is
for the love of
great big bazongas
hi oh you are unfun you are the opposite
of fun
okay all right okay so i just gotta keep
wind damn it wind everything's fine
hello why is this not working twice it's
not working we're wine damn it
wine
wine oh [ __ ] okay
hi ho you're horrible okay
wine look [ __ ] hey how you doing
okay look wine wine wind
[ __ ] okay you go away okay you're good
okay you're good
okay get it off
okay we're fine see this is called oh
[ __ ] i don't know what to do about that
um i don't know what to do about that
ah nope that ain't gonna work okay that
ain't gonna cut it
okay you just gotta get flashed i think
i think i don't know is this right this
doesn't feel right what's happening
what's happening what's happening what's
happening
no no no i don't know okay uh [ __ ] [ __ ]
blind you're back okay you're back
that's fine
if you're back that's fine whined oh my
god
you stupid sticky fingers okay we're
fine
so you don't move i just gotta be real
gentle about the problem i'm having
is that i'm panicking and if i panic
nothing good is ever gonna happen to me
can you please okay that's some flicks
can i please
oh okay i don't know what that's about
oh [ __ ] hi i don't know what what did
that do
what happened wow [ __ ] holy [ __ ] hi
oh my god you're the worst okay
wine wine oh god why wine
if you go did you go ah dude [ __ ]
hi hello mother of
god just leave me alone and whine
okay we're fine oh you you you you look
like
i don't know why that happens or what it
does
look it's like a flicking feels good
hi all right we're good click flick hi
hello
click click flick click flick flick
flick nothing's gonna kill me
nothing's gonna wind oh my god okay
we're fine
we're fine click clickety flick flickety
flick flick
clickety flick flick okay we're fine i
don't know if that's correct
but it sure [ __ ] feels correct
oh boy okay that's what i do for fly
foxy i can only assume for
anti-foxy that it's oh [ __ ] that it's
just as good just as effective you
suck you suck no take it off get there
you you you whine why whined
oh my god whined and dined hey
what [ __ ] off no yeah yeah yeah you
weren't even there
yes easy first try
i'm the best
easy easy easy even though the winder
didn't whine too good
oh look at you it's me healthy
oh help me or are you funtime fredbear
you got me my disguise didn't work
oh yeah well this is going to work on
you
all right so now comes that
three and this one actually might be a
little difficult i'm gonna try to do the
trick
where i keep them over in camera one but
if it's just
stupid a little bit and not enough i
think maybe i'm gonna have to
try to fiddle the little something
something a little different okay we're
gonna turn
whoa what the hell oh
um
excuse me pardon me
wait a minute
all right so that's a that was an issue
i can't [ __ ] you i'll [ __ ] you up yeah
that's right that's right that's right
i've rolled
i did i'm gonna call you immediately and
you're gonna close that
immediately you're going to shut up
immediately you're going to be
that immediately i don't know why i did
that ahead of time
there she goes again i don't know why
i don't know where he is and i don't
know why he is and i don't know where he
went
where how how how are you there
how are you there how are you there oh
my god how are you there
come on come
oh [ __ ] okay that's no good um okay all
right he's coming there
i ain't looking at you i ain't looking
at you oh [ __ ] audio error
that's the opposite of what we want oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] don't
go through that one there okay could i
please where is he oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he's
already moved on
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] where is he
okay come on back here okay there we go
that's what i didn't want okay there's
foxy over
there holy [ __ ] okay we're gonna move
him over here
he's gonna move he's gonna if i know he
is i know he is i know he is because i
got the flickiest wrist in the west
the flickiest like [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] where is he oh [ __ ] okay well
i'm doomed
doomed
oh [ __ ] i'm doomed i don't know where he
is i don't know where he went
i don't know
okay well we're doomed we're doomed
we're doomed
doomed
[Music]
oh he's an event isn't he oh [ __ ]
they're really really really really
oh [ __ ] i'm dead aren't i oh [ __ ]
oh yeah i'm dead okay this is all i can
do
[ __ ] did he go he's just he's gone
did he bugged out or something i don't
know where he is
uh he i think he's an event somewhere
but honestly
i can't see him anywhere so i'm just
gonna
nelly
i don't know what's happening i don't
know why it's happening he's gone
but uh maybe i should just count my
blessings because for some reason i
think i'm keeping them in
like purgatory for some reason i don't
know why
but uh oh what the [ __ ]
oh that's just i thought those were eyes
okay i don't know
where he is i don't know what he do oh
[ __ ] there i go
can't see oh [ __ ] that was the wrong one
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die
i'm dying i'm dying i really really am
dying
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god oh this what the
[ __ ] is happening
am i crazy hello am i crazy or maybe i
sent him into the dark zone just by
spamming this button so
hard and heavy and fast he can't take
these
he can't take my level of fiddle this
detail can't handle fiddling of this
magnitude
i'm alone on a thursday night is how i
do
you like some of that well what if i hit
you with my finishing move
oh yeah you can't handle none of this
yeah yeah you close
you're close yeah kick this
and this and take some of that too one
of these
picks up yeah eat my
gong i'm pretty sure pretty sure i
bugged that out
oh i've already had a conversation with
you
my big sister's gonna your pictures are
not gonna do nothing
i'm in nightmare mode i'm gonna come
after all y'all no
not like this oh exactly like this but
you know what i'm not gonna hurt you oh
thank you no it's not a favor
i'm gonna make you watch as i destroy
everything you've ever loved
no no don't do that it's too late i'm
coming for you guys
i'm coming for all y'all yeah
man i got a problem i should probably be
worried about that should i be worried
about that
is that a no i don't know what this
means okay
hi buddy so what that leaves
is just the dark rooms
these the dark rooms here and then
whatever the hell that is that's what's
left
so we're gonna pick that up in the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed this
it's good to know that i've still got
bugs and exploits to beat this [ __ ] into
the ground
on my side so thank you again there's
more five nights at freddy's stuff
in the description below and uh as
always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
you